here are the latest calls between former
President Obama and President Trump I'm
on vacation yes I know I can see you on
the 14th days you're using our
satellites to track me actually it's a
drone want me to take up the water
hazard on 16 I can do that question I'm
a little fuzzy on the line of succession
okay if something happens to you your VP
takes over then Speaker of the House
then president pro tempore of the Senate
very relaxing up until just now hey
listen I just wanted you to know you are
welcome to visit the White House
whatever you want anytime at all that's
very nice of you and while you're here
if you want to sit in on a security
briefing for review some federal budget
you just want me to do your job for you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what are you talking about incompetent
staff terrible policy ideas you've done
all that okay fine but you left its feet
up in the Oval Office Ben was with me oh
wait never mind that was Kelly Ann I'm
so tired of signing these executive
orders you know you don't have to sign
them all you can think about the first
yeah but my friend said if I sign them
all today I can watch my story and as
juice juice dying is only a mostly no
fish they've been stealing my medicine
breath
people to get these
you